[Musique]
bonjour gilbert pago bonjour bulletin
membres du groupe ' révolution
socialiste et soutien de philippe poutou
candidat du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste le des onze qualifié
pour la présidentielle française des
mois d'avril et de mai prochain
l'actualité politique et gilbert pago ce
matin c'est d'abord le décès d'henri
emmanuelli alors secrétaire d'état à
l'outre-mer entre 81 et 83 une réaction
de votre part
oui je me souviens de ce jeu de mini ce
qui était arrivé en 35 ans 81 est âgé de
35 ans et qui a un peu bousculé la vie
politique telle qu'elle existait à la
menthe unique puisque il est intervenu
je me souviens le contre l'ancien maire
de sainte luce ou bien celui du marc
mattera bon ça avait fait beaucoup de
bruit et il s'était montré très
dynamique voilà ces quatre là qui
quiconque on retiendra également dont on
retiendra qu'il installe et les conseils
régionaux dans le début des années 80
notre actualitté c'est ce débat hier
avec ce que tf1 a choisi de qualifier
comme étant les cinq plus gros candidats
à la présidentielle votre candidat votre
seul que vous soutenez phélippeau tour
n'était pas c'est un déni de démocratie
selon vous un scandale c'est un déni de
démocratie moi je ne il est inadmissible
de faire des élections et puis déjà de
prix choisir qui va être élu qui aura le
plus de voix alors il fallait organiser
peut-être ce débat autrement parce que
bon j'ai vu qu'il a duré trois heures
aux cinq personnes donc pour les onze
buts est qu'il aurait duré sept heures
donc ce raid est trop long peut-être
qu'il aurait fallu faire plusieurs
débats couper les thèmes étaient des
rats mais mettre tout le monde face à
face quand avez vous pensé de ce débat
les thèmes chers à philippe poutou votre
candidat avons ont-ils été suffisamment
abordé a maintenant bien sûr que non
vous avez vous aviez vous aviez laier la
représentant de l'extrême droite
vous aviez un représentant du centre
droit monsieur mapon
vous avez
la droite dure avec monsieur fillon et
puis vous aviez deux partis de gauche
divisée qui est un présent et qui se bat
là vous avoir
lequel va dépasser l'autre donc on
n'avait pas vraiment tous les thèmes
vous savez philippe poutou pourquoi nous
le soutenons c'est le seul candidat des
ouvriers c'est ça d'abord c'est un
ouvrier jus précisé le seul mais c'est
d'abord un ouvrier qui est en boîte vous
avez qu ils risquent d'être licenciés
vous avez que lorsqu'il est sorti par
exemple dimanche et d'une manifestante
interview à tf1
en sortant il a été contrôlé par la
police brutalement et photos qui sont en
train de circuler
donc vous voyez de il s'agit d'un
candidat quand même qu'il y a une
stature
ensuite il est anticapitaliste et c'est
ça qui nous réjouit de son point de vue
il est aussi anticolonialiste parce que
son parti qui comprend quelques uns
comme olivier besancenot bains sont
partis en 2009 avait envoyé olivier
besancenot temps à la martinique à la
guadeloupe prêt pour suivre les
événements de 2009 est organisée aussi à
paris et dans plusieurs villes de
province en france des manifestations
sur 2009 et enfin il représente pour
nous un des instincts des pros ça que
nous avions interrogé des gens comme
artaud mélenchon et poutou nous aurions
peut-être dû ajouter à mon à l'époque et
n'étaient pas sûrs à el al et perçait et
bien nous les avons interrogés parce que
pour nous il est important pour nous
martiniquais nous antillais de de
pouvoir relier les luttes qui se mène
ici en martinique avec les luttes mais
sous l'ère telles qu'elles sont mineures
franchement et lui comment vous
organisez une des garanties
comment faire la différence entre
philippe poutou du npa nathalie arthaud
de lutte ouvrière et jean luc mélenchon
de la france est soumise tous candidat
antisystème tout tout seul
candidats se revendiquant de la défense
des ouvriers bon les mots antisystème
d'abord je rejette ça mais nous ne
reviendrons mais vous savez par exemple
que mélenchon qui par ailleurs un
certain nombre d'idées intéressantes
mais par exemple et contre absolument
l'anticolonialisme un lui il parle de la
france présente sur les cinq continents
il se bat pour la grande france des cinq
continents il parle aussi de quelque
chose qui me bat intéressant à savoir
faire une assemblée constituante mais
pour ce qui est d'une assemblée
constituante pour les antilles il n'en
parle pas parce que lui et les en corpo
la présence souverainiste de la france
donc ça c'est quand même un gros
handicap
même si par ailleurs même si par
ailleurs il y a dans son programme
quelques points intéressants
marine le pen revendique également de
d'être là pour les ouvriers
d'ailleurs les ouvriers qui vaudra à 40%
pour elle aussi marine le pen est en
campagne électorale marine le pen elle
dit qu'elle est là pour les ouvriers
mais vous savez quand elle dit qu'elle
est anti système
il y a une formule qui dit d'elle
qu'elle est une anti du système
vous savez un son château de saint-cloud
ces familles les problèmes qu'ils ont
comme et touchent de l'argent n'importe
comment et en fait en plus dans ce parti
le nombre de gens qui sont poursuivis
pour des excroquerie avec un autre homme
quand même en tête des intentions de
vote
oui mais parce qu'elle développe un
langage anti immigrés et anti noir anti
arabes
parce que pour elle le seul problème ce
qui selon elle est en train de ruiner la
france
si le rsa qui a accordé ou aux gens de
ayant un revenu insuffisant mais ça
représente quelque chose comme 6
milliards mais par contre lorsqu il y à
des détournements de près de 60
milliards
ces sagas des détournements de cela ils
sont pas poursuivis
ça sent il me semble que ce qui ruine la
france c'est plus le détournement de 60
biya que les 6 milliards qui sont
accordées à quelques malheureux 1,15 %
c'était le chiffre obtenu par
philippe pour tous lors de la dernière
présidentielle lorsqu'on voit que c'est
quelqu'un qui hier encore était sûr dans
son usine neuve ford pour tenter de
sauver des employés qui ont couru dans
son musique qui nous ennuie en plein air
par les langues dont il n'a pas les
moyens de faire campagne est ce que
quelque part ça ne relève pas presque du
du du folklore la présence de philippe
poutou dans cette élection il faudrait
que vous enleviez le mou le folklore je
crois que les reconnaît qu'il n'a pas
les moyens de faire campagne qui doit
être sur son lieu de travail le rapport
aux grosses écuries il arrêterait de
chevreau contre il est en train de
défendre une idée à savoir que la
politique et mais ça doit être fait par
les citoyens ça doit être fait par la
population que la politique ne doit pas
être est réservée à quelques individus
qui peuvent se permettre en étant élu
après l'emploi et toute la famille
qu'ils soient du ps où qu'ils soient de
la droite du rhin vous avez entendu tout
donc il est en train de montrer que la
politique doit être mené parce qu'ils
sont sur le terrain parce que c'est ça
lorsqu'un service aux incidents qui les
anti système
il est anti système capitaliste oui et
comment faire donc pour faire prendre
cette saisie des comment pourquoi
pourquoi caracoler seulement avec 1,15
fonçant dessus des tensions que ça veut
dire comme un coup les caisses pour soi
lorsqu'on défend de telles idées
pourquoi ça ça ne fait pas ça ne prend
pas davantage même d'abord parce que
vous l'avez vu un
vous avez vu comment la presse organise
ses candidats non seulement ils
organisent les élections mais après
c'est eux qui ont promis qu'il fait sur
le terrain ne serait ce que pour obtenir
ses parrainages grâce au parrainage
parce que c'était s'adapter gagné
c'était une grosse bataille ça a été une
grosse bataille politique est l'argument
était d'ailleurs de dire aux gens quand
vous soutenez quand vous le parrainer ce
n'est pas parce que vous approuvez ses
idées mais c'est parce que vous dites
que il ya là quelqu'un qui représente un
courant politique en france et que ce
courant politique a le droit de
s'exprimer par exemple les mères
martiniquais qui ont signé pour bhutto
ils sont cinq à avoir signé pour vous
tous ils vont pas voter pour bhutto
absolument pas ils l'ont fait parce que
ils ont voulu accords qu'ils ont tendu
en tous les cas cet argument que nous
leur avons présentement vous ferez
campagne ici en martinique pour
philippoteaux gilbert badiou et les amis
du groupe sur les trois points que je
voulais des d'abord nous allons faire
une campagne anti colonialiste son ubu
couteau défendent anticoloniale et nous
allons faire une campagne anti
capitaliste chez les poteaux défend
l'anticapitalisme nous allons faire une
campagne pour dire que nous sommes pour
l'unité de lutte des travailleurs entre
ceux des colonies et ceux de la france
et ça il défend cette idée
pour nous c'est important et enfin il
nous allons faire une campagne pour dire
que ce sont les citoyens qui doivent
diriger la politique c'est ça qui est
important pour nous alors vous avez les
1,15 pour cent au moins ce que ça moi je
ne sais pas ce qui va ce que va donner
cette élection c'est pas ça l'essentiel
l'essentiel des c'est d'essayer de faire
passer ses idées
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nous
dans sampler dit gilbert pago on
rappelle qu'un pauvre et membre du
groupe révolution socialiste et soutien
à philippe pourtour du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste merci bonne journée
[Musique]